fans of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
got an early Christmas present when it
was announced in December 17 that Disney
would be acquiring a large portion of
Fox including the movie rights did the
x-men and the Fantastic Four with the
dream of a unified MCU finally on the
verge of becoming reality let's look at
all the best Marvel characters Disney is
getting from Fox Wolverine and the x-men
obviously the biggest question for fans
is what Marvel will do with Fox's
massive x-men franchise which is so far
produced three solo Wolverine films as
well as six x-men movies with a seventh
on the way in 2018 merging the x-men
franchise with the MCU would be a
massive undertaking should they recast
the roles and reboot the x-men entirely
or should they use the x-men franchises
frequent timeline shifts and read cons
to simply add the whole existing x-men
universe to the MCU if you thought
understanding the x-men films was
difficult before get ready for a wild
ride will Wolverine make the leap
Michael the Fantastic Four even though
they've appeared in only four movies to
date the Fantastic Four have never truly
worked on screen so for fans the most
exciting thing about the Disney Fox
merger is the possibility that we'll
finally get a good Fantastic Four movie
so far they've been well two guys a girl
and the thing that nobody wanted at
their heart the Fantastic Four
aren't superheroes they're adventurers
using science and superpowers to explore
other dimensions other realities and the
unknown depths of our universe films
like Thor the guardians of the galaxy
and Doctor Strange have introduced some
of the weirder corners of the MCU to
fans but it's the Fantastic Four who are
best designed to explore them we can't
wait Galactus
the biggest and baddest villain in the
Marvel Universe Galactus literally eats
planets for breakfast so fans were
terribly disappointed when Fox wasted
him in Fantastic Four rise of the Silver
Surfer by showing him as just an angry
space cloud instead of the world
devouring giant from the comics
of course the lactis never goes anywhere
alone and his coming to disney also
means that Marvel Studios has the right
suit all his heralds not just the Silver
Surfer
but others including the loyal Airwalker
the villainous morg
the adventurous Nova and the ambitious
Terrax once Thanos is through as a
threat don't be surprised if you start
hearing rumblings of Galactus as the
next big bad worthy of a franchise
spanning team-up Silver Surfer speaking
of The Sentinel of the spaceways the
Silver Surfer didn't exactly blow people
away when he made his big screen debut
in 2006 but his tragic story of
sacrifice and loss where he gives up his
freedom to save humanity is timeless add
in his iconic design and you have a
character with the potential to be a
breakout star in the MCU Deadpool fans
have to be salivating at the idea of
Deadpool joining the Marvel Cinematic
Universe some of the funniest jokes in
the surprise 2016 smash hit film
involved Ryan Reynolds playing off the
straight-laced x-men it's a big house
it's funny that I only ever see two of
you it's almost like the studio couldn't
afford another x-men now imagine what
he'll do when he runs into characters
like Doctor Strange Tony Stark or even
spider-man we can't wait to hear the
one-liners fly Legion it's safe to say
that nobody outside of hardcore comic
book fans had ever heard of the
character Legion until FX debuted the
critically acclaimed TV series starring
Downton Abbey's Dan Stevens now though
the character provides some intriguing
possibilities thanks to his connection
to the x-men universe through deadbeat
dad Professor Xavier and his
reality-warping powers could be a handy
way to easily ride him into any
franchise the honchos at marvel studios
once the possibilities are endless and
intriguing the new mutants the next
generation of students at Charles
Xavier's school for gifted cannon fodder
the new mutants are finally coming
the big scream in 2018 with a horror
tinge adaptation of the classic demon
bear storyline while the film only
focuses on a handful of characters
including magic Wolfsbane cannonball
sunspot and Mirage the new mutants
lineup also includes a number of other
fan favorites like karma warlock and
magma traditionally aimed at a slightly
younger demographic than x-men it will
be interesting to see how or if the new
mutants fit into the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Alpha Flight in February 2017
x-men producers Simon Kinberg made
reference to an in the works ex flight
movie which many took to be referring to
a new version of the never before
adapted team alpha flight formed by the
Canadian government with the help of
Wolverine alpha flight has strong ties
to the x-men universe while maintaining
its own identity thanks to unique and
offbeat characters like shaman puck
Northstar Snowbird and Sasquatch in a
world where guardians of the galaxy have
become household names with a little
tender loving care for Marvel Studios
Alpha Flight could become the next big
thing Doctor Doom one of the most
awesome developments from the Disney Fox
deal doesn't involve the heroes it
brings to the MCU but rather the
villains and no Marvel Comics villain is
more thoroughly iconic than Doctor Doom
while doom is mostly known for his
eternal rivalry with the Fantastic Four
the ruler of Latveria has also gone
toe-to-toe with just about everyone else
in the MCU so far fans haven't been
thrilled with the way he's been
portrayed in the Fox movies so a doom
that actually lives up to the characters
great legacy in the comics would be a
very welcome change and if you think
otherwise Kang the Conqueror he's
considered to be the Avengers ultimate
arch enemy battling Earth's Mightiest
Heroes dozens of times over the decades
but thanks to a quirk in their licensing
deal the movie rights for Kang were
apparently shipped over to Fox along
with Fantastic Four meaning The Avengers
were left without their greatest foe now
though it's possible that the
time-traveling warlord Kang who has
conquered countless empires throughout
history
we'll finally get to set his sights on
the 21st century MCU all we can say is
it's about time thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you love to
[Music]